man so much so much to be happy about
right now you know we got a great show
tonight and uh
christmas just about a week away and you
know when when christmas gets close
everybody in manhattan everybody in the
united states gets into this great
holiday spirit
and i was noticing even here at the show
in fact uh
even one believe it or not even one of
our show's most despicable and
reprehensible characters
who's appeared on the show several times
is actually full of christmas joy
and you can see it i'm talking of course
about the masturbating bear
it's this character
this character the master betting bear
is easily one of our most controversial
characters on the show
he almost got us kicked off the air in
several states
i think we're intro it's getting dodgy
down in texas they don't like that
masturbating bear
but you know what i have noticed lately
he's really gotten into the christmas
spirit
and the masturbating bear asked me if he
could come out here tonight
and give away toys and presents and
candy to our studio audience
i wasn't sure
to be honest folks i really wasn't sure
and i'm wary of the masturbating bear
but he promised he'd be on his best
behavior
he wouldn't do anything dirty just be a
perfect gentleman so i thought
why not let's do it let's bring him out
here max can we have a little music
please
folks please welcome the masturbating
[Applause]
bear
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
stop it stop the music max everybody
stop
bear bear bear
bear stop it
[Applause]
how dare you a christmas show
i'm gonna have a word with you come here
come here yeah you
yeah i don't see another bear in a
diaper come on down
come on
[Applause]
i am sick of this you know
you've been coming on the show for a
couple of years now
and every time we get you to play the
bear and put the costume on
you assure me you're not going to do
that because it gets us in trouble
and every time you do it i promised the
network you wouldn't do it
and you put on the costume and you did
it in front of everybody i have just had
it with you
seriously i'm sick of it
no no andy come on you know what i'm
sorry i'm really no don't encourage him
i got it
flawless technique yeah
[Applause]
wish i had known you in 82 uh well
anyway
no seriously i'm gonna uh i'm tired of
this
i'm tired of this person we're gonna
start getting someone else
to play the masturbating bear because
what you do every time
it's just disgusting
pesky kids now now come on that is it i
don't demand your own business
all right matt could you take us out to
commercial and you come back and behave
[Music]
[Applause]
yourself